what are you gonna say babe so what
happened last week you I didn't want to
tell you this because it really put me
in a in a funk but I was talking to an
old friend who happened to talk to my
ex-boyfriend and I hadn't spoken to this
girl in a long time and she said oh yeah
I was trying to look for you on Facebook
I was like oh what prompted that she was
well I talked to you know your ex or
whatever and he's and word for verbatim
he was like oh you got to see what her
boyfriend looks like he's like a short
Chinese dude
and she said that that's what he said
like he was hating on basically you on
you who's a postive no no no no who Alex
the tattooed guy and so it just so
happens he's I guess she's with some
short Chinese dude now and it it put me
in a [ __ ] rage you know why it put me
in a rage because he knows exactly who
you are
he knows what she do for a living he
knows everything but his descriptor of
you to other people is just that and I
didn't know I wanted so badly to call
him in Medicaid why are you do you being
salty let me see something right now I'm
not Chinese even though you do a lot
people to call you [ __ ] yeah okay
only friends friends number two
I'm Shh not short for my ethnicity Oh
average a month average yeah number
three I'm sorry but I have every right
as a short Chinese dude I know your
average Korean but I have every right
the way I look - bang - bang girls out
of my [ __ ] league because that's the
point of life the point of life is to
reach out and reach for the stars yeah
okay if I dated a girl that God wanted
me to date which was a four foot nine
Vietnamese girl named Tring Tring I
would have done that but I get in
mm-hmm I looked at this girl on tinder
right here yeah you did
and I swipe right like that right and
guess what
I crawled inside her how did you live in
there a long time okay right and when I
went I crushed it and hey Alex go [ __ ]
yourself
boom you're just salty people go how
come she dates you I'll tell you why I
date you because for starters you figure
this enough you have a bigger penis than
him and also you
[Music]